and so the Harry Potter franchise
unleashes its truly
scariest villain and her name's Dolores
[Applause]
[Music]
Harry Potter in the order of the Phoenix
yes we continue working our way through
my revisit of the Harry Potter film
franchise and this one is interesting to
me for a number of reasons the first is
it's the only film in the entire
franchise where the screenplay was not
written by Steve Clovis he apparently
needed a break after doing Goblet of
Fire but he came right back after this
one this is the introduction of David
Yates beginning to direct and he will
take over the franchise from here the
rest directing the last four in the main
franchise and also directing fantastic
beasts when we get there and this is
also easily the book in the series that
I like the least I really did not enjoy
reading order of the Phoenix at all like
I'm not gonna say there was nothing I
liked about it but I had a hard time
working through this book if I were to
sum it up in one word it would be
Harry Harry drove me crazy in the fifth
book so like I get that as part of his
overall journey as a character and also
just part of being a teenager having a
phase where he's basically just kind of
an emotional time bomb and a bit of a
dick makes sense that's something a lot
of young people go through it makes
sense plus he's got a certain amount of
influence on him from dark forces yeah
no I get it it's not that him acting the
way he does in the book isn't justified
but as I continually beat on this drum
until people get it narrative Lee
justifying something doesn't mean
that I have to like it and I hate it but
I don't hate it in the movie all that
much there's one big key difference and
this is again gives me a nice way to
highlight the ways in which the medium
alters the story by the very nature of
how the medium works which is that a big
part of what was so infuriating to me
about this book reading it was that as
I've noted before Harry's is the only
thought process we we get eyes on it's
not true third-person omniscient we
don't get to get into the heads of
anybody other than Harry it sticks to
him you know we get little reads on
everyone else but he's the one who's
actual thought process we as readers are
privy to what that meant in or her the
Phoenix was I got I had to read his
incredibly faulty stupid thought
processes that he would go through that
would end up in him being really mad at
yelling at his friends and again it's
not that I don't buy that this was his
thought process again young teenager
going through a lot of crap I get it but
it's so infuriating me to have to read
this thought process that I know is
wrong is faulty and wrong and stupid and
to have to go and it's not even just
once in the book it's over and over and
over again every all these times the way
and again narrative Lee it makes sense
that he's feeling more isolated from his
friends and like oh it's all has a
purpose but I just hate reading it I
don't enjoy reading that book at all but
in the film because while we are still
stuck with some of Harry's actions we'd
aren't subjected to his thought process
which for me makes it so much easier to
deal with because yes I'm still stuck
with him acting a bit like a jerk and
pushing people away a bit needlessly but
I don't have to read his stupid thought
process as to why he's doing it I know
he's being an idiot without knowing
exactly how he connected a to B to C to
douche
Hey so I enjoyed the movie a heck of a
lot more than the book as far as having
David Yates and this this really is the
start of his aesthetic overall is very
just blue filter gray blue filter which
again totally makes a lot of sense and
as far as you know things are getting a
little bit darker overall and it did
make sense to have that reflect at least
a certain amount in the you know
visualization of the world itself I you
know I still kind of miss the brighter
vibrancy of the first two films
I really wish they'd done more to retain
that Goblet of Fire brought it back a
little bit for parts of it particularly
for seems like the Yule Ball or you know
the the earlier or some of the earlier
stuff going on with the goblet
challenges and the Quidditch tournament
but I feel like starting with this entry
a lot of the color has just been drained
out of the story again I get it I just
kind of miss I I would like the
reminders of why we fell in love with
this world in the first place again
though it powers through because at this
point I'm invested in these characters
in this story so it doesn't lose me
because it goes visually darker I'm just
saying you know do it as much as it does
as far as actual plot on this one goes
now that Harry is more palpable to me
and also take this with a grain of salt
because it's been a while since I've
reread this book I'm not leaning forward
to ever doing so but my feeling was that
the movie did a lot better job at
selling house starting to teach what he
knew to other students helped ground
Harry I felt like that came across much
better here than it did in the book
again maybe it's because I was still
stuck with the stupid awful thought
processes with Harry and was just
muddling everything where is this I get
to see the change in performance and
just see oh man that really is helping
Center him and all of this cool and that
that helps me get through the
thing as well we've got a handful of new
characters we have the wonderful Luna
Lovegood that oh god that was such good
casting she's just she's just perfect
for this part and and the kids who have
been around the whole time they're just
they they know these characters very
well as they are choosing to play them
and they have a great rapport with each
other and that continues to be the case
as far as the grown-ups we have a couple
who get highlighted we get a little bit
of stuff with Dumbledore but he's kind
of background is a little bit kind of by
necessity because Dumbledore is avoiding
Harry for a lot of this although I do
like the way that they handled the
blow-up of Harry when Harry yells at him
look at me and just sort of show me how
exasperated Harry was that that was good
stuff and Dumbledore Gambon's really
bringing this sense of concern and you
can tell the whole situation is kind of
just weighing on him as a character as a
human being and especially with some of
the stuff that we find out later about
all this that's super appropriate snake
gets a little bit more to do he's got
some he gets to sort of dig into Harry a
little bit by teaching him how to trying
to teach him how to shield his mind
which is again a really good set up for
stuff about Snape that we find out later
realizing that Snape is really good at
this becomes a major plot point and it's
it all builds really well in sleep Scott
he's got wonderful moments like when
he's talking to umbrage and and Harry
tells him yo they've got he's got
Padfoot he's got Padfoot in the place
where it's hidden and I'm just like what
is he talking about I'm saying just
pause no idea and leaves no one could
have done that better than recommended
oh god it's so good and you've also got
of course Gary Oldman back as series
black the death of Sirius doesn't hit me
like it's supposed to
now that's actually true of both the
book and the movie it happens so
suddenly and so weirdly I think having
him fall back into that veil thing
really muddles the moment both on the
page
as I remember it and in the screen
because I remember thinking like does
that mean he's not just dead cuz it's
like something weird happened there and
it's and it's weird and odd and it
because I felt like I didn't fully
understand what had happened that it
sucks a lot of the a lot of the impact
of the moment out
I felt that about the book and I feel
that about the movie I feel like the
movie does that a little bit better but
it is a little bit frustrating
especially considering how impactful
Cedric Diggory death a little bit less
than death itself but see how it
impacted the other characters how great
that was done in Goblet of Fire to the
fact that it doesn't quite land in this
one I think the idea to drop out the
sound when Harry realizes that Sirius is
gone he starts screaming and Lupin has
to pull him away sound has dropped out
completely that could have worked for
Talan we should have gotten one initial
yell out of Harry instead it goes silent
immediately and again like if I could
have heard the pain in his voice the way
I heard from Cedric's dad the pain in
his voice it would have sold the moment
a heck of a lot better but then instead
they decided to go all artsy fartsy and
drop the sound out immediately and it
doesn't kill the moment but it does
weaken it it doesn't hit nearly as hard
as it should
we've got Bellatrix Lestrange
introducing this she's really good for a
psychotic minion she just works for that
Voldemort facing off against Dumbledore
that's a really cool battle it's given
that we've been dealing with students up
to this point by and large it's really
cool to see what do two really powerful
wizards facing off what does that look
like and I don't think it really
disappoints to much it's a very cool
battle that the two of them engage in
it's very well done now though huh I
hinted at this at the opening Dolores
Umbridge possibly one of the most
infinitely hateable characters in
literature and film holy
rap do you hate her do I hate her does
everyone hate her
I think a lot we will hate her more than
Baltimore truth be told there's just
something about this you know this
pleasant smile like what I'm going to
now do this awful thing and you can't
stop me oh but it is also very rewarding
when things don't go her way and she
starts getting very flustered or got one
one of the most cathartic moments and
the movie captures it pretty well but I
do think it was slightly more cathartic
on the page is the twins with their big
exit and stealing a cue from The Hobbit
and having a dragon made of fireworks
and having it chase after her oh that
was rewarding and everybody else is just
good so despite the I mean this should
be the thing this is a one of my
favorite movies in the series but I do
enjoy it which given that I really
didn't enjoy reading the book and again
not to say that it is a bad book but to
say that what it's doing I did not take
pleasure in reading for the movie to
just be as pleasant and as enjoyable and
as much fun and as something that I'm so
willing to revisit whereas the book very
much isn't that should say a lot
regardless of where this ends up
ultimately laying and landing when I
rank these things at the end of this
whole revisit it's I honestly for me for
me for my taste for what I found
infuriating about the book this is the
one entry in the Harry Potter franchise
where I say I like the movie better than
the book I'm not gonna make a bull save
more like it is definitively better let
know me personally I like this better
than the book how many people are gonna
lash me over for those comments
ah how much of this was a review of the
movie and how much of it was me ripping
on what I couldn't stand about the book
I don't know 50 50 40 60 somebody
workout in any case Harry Potter and the
order of the Phoenix you we have you
read watched it lately what are your
thoughts on it whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it
bunch of stuff to do as well hit the
like hit the subscribe hit the bell hit
the link from my patreon help me out I
greatly appreciate it or you know you
also don't have to because at the end of
the day you're the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]